[Music]
this is um
a clip and now the title of this clip is
how to spot a narcissist now this is old
video right but i thought it was
interesting and i thought you'd want to
watch it okay
the comment i'd like to give you is
you sure the name of this video isn't
how to spot three narcissists
oh good point yeah sorry how to spot
well are you kidding me are you sure
hold on hold on hold on
are you sure the people watching this
video aren't going how to spot six
narcissists that's a good point well
five and then a dog five and a half a
five and an off-screen dog right
common i'd like to give you is that you
laugh at me and that's so that's that's
a nice thank you that's a really good
and that's all i want really from you
yeah that's one of the signs of
narcissism too yeah yeah
we were we're like i've been googling
narcissism all day yeah that's kind of
narcissistic isn't it
[Laughter]
i've been googling narcissism all day
and just pictures my girlfriend keep up
did you know she [ __ ] jerked off dogs
yeah this picture's over doing it mm-hmm
denial i've been denied i don't think
you are i don't think i'm going to show
you a questionnaire i think the reason
that he thinks he's he's i think it this
is an older video like i said but i
think the reason that he thinks that
he's a narcissist is because she's
telling him the real narcissist is
telling him that he is one i don't think
all right well i'm going to show you a
questionnaire and let's just you want to
go through it i can tell you i've known
you forever i don't think you're a
narcissist i don't yeah in fact i think
remember this is when they were still
talking so this is before the
incidents i think you're the opposite i
think that you are you might be
self-destructive and you may have set
low self-esteem all the good things that
the comic needs yeah but i don't think
that you're a narcissist at all in fact
and i'll tell you you always go out of
your way to try to empower other people
that's what i thought always thought
about myself
but what but what that's what he always
thought about himself but what
but she disagrees with you i not only do
i disagree i think you are
the prototype for narcissism like
going back and watching this right she's
horrible
you're the prototype for narcissism
again
breaking this man this is a woman thing
by the way every time a woman is mad at
a man or a relationship or a
relationship goes bad but the guy
technically didn't do anything like
didn't cheat on her
or didn't hit her or you know maybe that
she didn't get along
or maybe it was her fault the excuse
that women always using you know i'm 100
right ladies because you have friends
that use it oh the guy was a total
narcissist the guy was just a total
narcissist that's the you see it all the
time too i'm sure emerge but it's just
women going it's because he was a
narcissist yeah
but when mercy hears it it's true oh no
that's true
you are the exact if you
just read the book bobby your phone's
free why is my girl why is my steve's
girlfriend calling me because your thing
is attached to her
yeah but again he's a narcissist i don't
want to i don't want to [ __ ] but
here's the questions all right let me go
to the questions all right
the first one is you like to be the
center of attention well that's
that's everything is every any comedian
anybody does a show really that's that
that just means you're a performer
that's what i'm saying that just means
you're a [ __ ] comic and you and you
love the sensation of you happen to have
a skill set that's very rare no wonder
brian now you know what i might be like
team bryan calendar but no other brian
callum was so mad at them
which is you can make people double over
in laughter okay right so you're really
good but not in a jamie foxx movie
because she will not allow it
because it's the idea because she
doesn't want you to play an asian mm-hmm
in a movie
can i make a position
are very good in their work field
they're charming they're well-liked from
from from a distance being good at work
does it make you
this do you know what peop women trying
to convince men their narcissists are
the same women that believe that the
reason that they have a headache is
because mercury isn't retrograde you
know it's always crystal people it's
always people that [ __ ] met
first off i'm not gonna be told i'm a
narcissist by somebody who [ __ ] two of
her brothers so let's start there no the
moment that you [ __ ] one of your
brothers i had already i'm not going to
take anything you say seriously brother
you said you looked you looked and was
exactly like you in every way and then a
stepbrother and literally [ __ ] the
male version of yourself
who's the narcissist here
he acted like we were just like we could
just tell we were like you know kind of
related it's like okay then you're
literally trying to [ __ ]
yourself god she's so annoying she's the
woman but they're very difficult to live
with that's okay but that's not the way
to death she is the worst person
in any room she walks into yes seriously
final narcissist narcissist is the hero
or the victim of every story he tells
that's her though
okay okay there we go okay here
um
shames or humiliates um those who agree
uh disagree with him like you're doing
with him right now
hold on hold on hold on hold on
like you're doing with him right now
often goes in the attack when hurt or
frustrated
like you did with brandon schwab
exploding with rage
this is this is um
i'm just protecting my how about
throwing tantrums or even breaking laws
with minimal consequences
i feel like incest is illegal yeah and
nothing happening off dogs is also yeah
zoophilia is also
[ __ ] illegal well i mean not in
canada i guess anymore
lizer distorts the truth for personal
gain blames others or makes excuses
i'll tell you what i as my job as a
comedian yeah
so
she just described herself
yeah
too bobby's the problem though
because you know they're all terrible
people i don't care let that whole
[ __ ]
place fall off into the ocean